good morning Millennials welcome back to
the morning toast I have extra energy
this morning because it is the earliest
we've ever recorded the toast so Claude
hid hey guys happy Tuesday it's so early
where we are we have a very busy day
which is why we had to get started on
this early but I'm excited to dive in
chitchat do all the things I gotta do
and say we have never recorded the toast
this early in our lives so let's see if
we're really morning people I know for a
fact that I'm not but I feel like I
don't know I feel like I'm going to the
airport which is an exciting phenomenon
in the queue been like I've never in my
life open up before been like ever and I
have a feeling he's gonna come out any
minute cuz I'm like being loud but I'm
sorry you're working yeah I'm on the
clock I clocked him so where is Theodore
of the Chaman he's roaming around the
dining room table yes living room for
those watching on zoom I'm now in my
living room cuz I don't want like been
sleeping in the back of my zoom I just
thought that would be like ugly so Theo
sup he's working early as well he's
working the room he's walking around the
hallways you know just taking inventory
of what's going on nice very nice
it wasn't so as bad waking up early as I
thought it was gonna be but I went to
sleep a little bit early I was reading
all night reading the redheads book it
is such a good book I'm almost done with
it I'm gonna be like sad and excited
when it's over but I'm excited to record
the episode because I think this was a
real quality book if you haven't read it
yet I think this might be like my
favorite has we've done so far so
exciting well I was actually thinking
last night about how I started the
redheads book and I don't know how you
guys do a book a month like I've been
reading for two days and I read 25 pages
like I don't know how you guys read so
fast like I would like not be able to
keep up with the redheads grueling
schedule no the schedule is grueling
regardless but in quarantine we were
doing two books a month so it's every
two weeks and we're done doing that now
because um you know things are getting
back to normal
little bit but it was who's a lot you
know I feel like I will finish my Angela
book like by the summer yeah well our
next episode drops like the first
Thursday of July like oh I'm sorry it is
the summer I thought it was like March
for a second I mean the winter or maybe
is all the weirdest thing ever is like
we went into this thing in March and it
still feels like the world is on pause
and we're waiting to on pause yet like
we are very much in June like you could
be wearing all white if you wanted to I
think the most unfair thing about
quarantine was that it happened like
during the strictly during the spring
months which are like the best months
for a million different reasons like we
had to suffer through winter and now
we're gonna suffer through like a steamy
hot New York and we never got spring
yeah I agree my allergies are alright
with that but it it was cruel
it was grow it was a cruel summer with
the good that was that was not your best
oh my gosh I went on tick-tock for the
first time in one whole month yesterday
like I do not remember the last time I
was on tick-tock
I was scrolling on my free page and I
hear the voice of an angel you singing
defying gravity I tried to tell you like
I literally tried to tell I had no idea
what you were talking about you said
this guy he does a video anyway sing but
I didn't know that like you were singing
and he was accompanying that's what I'm
saying like by the way I'm just trying
to give you a compliment I'm trying to
say something nice I just don't think
you should be so surprised by my talent
you know I've literally been singing for
you every day of my life like since we
were born never said it was surprised
very talented surprised to see you on my
for you page when I had clearly had so
much content to catch up on from my
mother's hiatus wasn't that beautiful
Claudia that was beautiful
yes calmly special coming at you June
30th available for pre-order on iTunes
check it out Claudia outrageous grace
Queen yes um okay well we have a great
show for you today
not much sure recap cuz I didn't watch a
lot of TV yesterday I just was trying to
read out weirdly so busy these this week
is
crazy does he press we have a lot going
on um outside of the queue which is
crazy um so do you want to just get
right into it yeah we have some mindless
news which I'm excited about
and we have uh I want to recap some
something I watched on Instagram
yesterday not on TV I literally did not
turn my TV on um okay I will happily
recap what you watch on Instagram
because when I called you you were
watching it and told me to watch it so I
watched it so I'm happy to recap right
alongside you put before that before
that it is time for the Fast Five
stories that you need to know before you
wake up and take a bite out of your
morning toast
and that's true Jax but I just need a
minute I need a minute because I don't
know if anyone knows but I'm literally
like the face and the body of today's
sponsor Beachbody on demand it comes as
no surprise that we're all stuck in our
homes for a while
avoid the complacency it's important now
more than ever to it keep active and
keep moving forward work out and take
classes in the comfort of your own home
with Beachbody on demand the easy-to-use
streaming service that gives you instant
access to over 1,300 super effective
workouts suited for anybody at any time
the secret to getting results is just
getting started this is the company
behind p90x insanity and 21 day fix now
you can check out some of beach body's
newest programs like the morning
meltdown an 80-day obsession and start
every day strong they have some of the
best trainers you can get motivated by
super trainers you know like Tony Horton
Jill Freeman Jericho McMath use and
autumn Calabrese they have some of the
best programs hundreds of effective
workouts for all fitness levels ranging
from bodybuilding to weight training to
cardio to yoga and even dance workouts
workouts can be as short as 10 minutes
they don't require extra equipment
either super easy to do in your house if
you're still stuck in the queue and even
if you're not still stuck in thank you
you can access it at anywhere at any
time either on your computer your TV
tablet smartphone Roku Apple TV
chromecast I just got Apple TV like its
game-changer so I will definitely
getting my beach body in my bedroom and
listen if the listeners of the morning
shows can try it absolutely free if you
follow this if you want to try this
service our listeners can get a special
free trial membership when you text
toast to 30 30 30 you'll get full access
to the entire platform for
all the workouts nutritional information
and support totally free but you just
have to text toast TOA st to 30 30 30
that's the free trial if you text toast
to 30 30 30 sign on get a Beachbody
I love Beachbody I can't believe that
we're well into month three in
quarantine
and I have like this whole well-rounded
workout routine um thanks to the likes
of Beachbody and things are goes okay
it's now actually uses Beachbody in the
snatchers looking like this natural
recently the snatchler is Beachbody like
she is the she's the body of Beachbody
okay let's separate him okay first story
bachelor fans create a petition to cast
the first black bachelor Tyler Cameron
and more alums to share support in its
18 year history the bachelors franchise
has only ever featured one black lead
bachelor nation is ready to see some
change franchise alums like Tyler
Cameron Rachel Lindsay Lauren Burnham CN
fleming nicole lopez al VAR nick vial
diggie Moreland and more have signed a
change.org petition titled a campaign
for anti racism in The Bachelor
franchise demanding more diversity and
representation amid the black lives
matter movement over 20,000 people have
signed the petition so far I mean this
is just like insane I didn't even
realize I knew that the the the show had
been on forever but the petition like
the social card that was going around it
said eighteen years forty seasons one
black lead that's insane and I feel like
especially in the last few weeks like
we've seen how important it is for the
platform rachel lindsay has like she's
just doing amazing things and the fact
that there's only one of her is a real
shame yes this is just it's bidonville a
long time coming for so long now now
it's up to the fans to make a petition i
hope that the Batchelor franchise
listens cuz this is what people want
yeah and you know what it seems so
strange like they almost go out of their
way not to choose because they had mike
johnson um like in the running most
recently and like they just went out of
their way to give it to Peter and after
the see
we got with Peter like I don't know if
anyone could have been a worse choice so
it's like out they went out of their way
to not give it to Mike Johnson even
though like the audience was very vocal
about wanting him to have it so it's
very strange and I read a quote um e
news posted about this and they posted a
quote from Rachel Lindsay talking about
this and Rachel was like 40 seasons like
that's almost as many presidencies like
you now have just as much of a chance as
becoming the president as a black person
than you do as becoming the lead of The
Bachelor franchise and honestly it was
like a hilarious and really weird men
are well yeah yeah not metaphor sorry
comparison I think yeah I think that was
a good word choice just like it's really
late it's really late so I mean who even
knows what's going on with The Bachelor
now like when it came to Clair season
and paradise and usually they start
filming The Bachelor in September so
they really have an opportunity right
now to just switch it up you know Claire
season it it doesn't have to happen the
way you know like if they could make
this change now and live to their
audience know that they hear them what
are your theories well that's true my
theory is that like first of all this is
not a theory just I think that in their
own weird way Bachelor make corporation
thought they were being like inclusive
by giving it to like an older woman you
know like so as not to be aegis but
that's not really the inclusivity like
people are demanding so I was just gonna
say that but that's not my theory my
theory is that like I feel like Claire
Crawley is just the type of person who's
like unlucky you know like and I think
that like they might actually take this
away from her just to give it to a more
diverse lead and that would just be like
so Claire Crawley do you know what I
mean 100 is so close and like if it
weren't for the pandemic that she would
have already filmed it yes it's like so
many things happened and she couldn't
become the lead I completely agree with
both of your points but I that was I
have another one oh but you shared to
two wonderful points no I said this one
was at a point it was just I don't it
was in a side okay he was in a side it
was the mashed potatoes um or I feel
like Tyler Cameron's friend Matt James
could start being groomed to be on the
next season and then ultimately be
chosen as the bachelor yeah that could
happen I could see that happening too or
if there's no bachelor at this season
there's no bachelor in paradise and they
just want to get right on track with
their usual scheduling programming and
film The Bachelor in September they
could choose Mike Johnson for once true
and for all you know yeah and it's not
like we have to get to know someone new
and we could just kind of like pick up
where we left off sort of yeah it's a
real you of Peters season that we
deserve oh my god like what a waste of
time it would be one thing if they like
you know like so obviously didn't choose
Mike Johnson and we got like an
incredible season out of it but we got
like a terrible bachelor yeah but at
least Mike Johnson got a date with Demi
Lovato
no I'm happy for him know that you are
um also I just remember when they
announced Rachel Lindsay is the first
black lead like it felt like this new
frontier you know and it was like a new
better bachelor but it just never really
um got there no they thought like their
work was done when in reality it was
just starting yeah it's just it's
actually crazy how long they've gotten
away with it
yeah I agree but now the fans are
demanding change yeah I hope that they
actually listen to bachelor nation I
hope so too
um Ana de Armas has a life-size cutout
of herself outside of her home um ana de
Armas appears to be having some fun with
the paparazzi who regularly swarm
outside her house parentheses after she
calls she calls him the knives out star
who is dating Ben Affleck now has a
life-sized card Bart life-size cardboard
cutout of herself on the lawn and she
apparently had a little help schlepping
it they're both two reports at Affleck's
three kids with ex Jennifer Garner
daughters violet Serafina and Samuel
pitched in with carrying it
the cuban-born actress and Ben Affleck's
have been dating since meeting on the
set of their film deep water in 2019
since then the actors have enjoyed
John's to Havana and Costa Rica so I
guess this is like a little prank on the
paparazzi
um and I just want to let you know like
there are some people who are getting
[ __ ] ya know would like before
quarantine like the way I reported on
them was just like ship ship ship ship
ship and now it's been a little while
since we spoke about them and I'm
officially here to say like they are a
joke like this is really disappointing
like how many you know steps they've
taken down from like a list they're
really reminding me of like like a sad
version of kamila and Shawn a hundred
percent and it's like they were in my
eyes so a list when they stepped on the
scene together and it looked like
someone truly caught them stepping on
the scene but now in quarantine like
they clearly had this whole PR rollout
for their relationship they had to amend
it with masks and dog walks and like
social distancing and it's just so corny
and um my ship dum has definitely shrunk
in size since the last time we spoke
about these two it's so corny and so
disappointing from what should have been
like to a list mega stars think this is
tacky as hell yeah like this is real
c-list behavior totally or like teeny
bopper behavior yeah or fake
relationship behavior PR stunts for our
movie behavior when it's like I actually
think they're in a real relationship
like you don't have your kids log a
picture a life-sized picture of your
girlfriend if you know she's not she's
lives in a real way or if she's like
your work girlfriend you know they are
so cute um I just don't know why they
keep doing this like why do they feel
the need to keep doing this like I think
a really brilliant narrative would have
been like if before quarantine we saw
those pictures of them on the beach like
those look just very candid like I don't
think that those were set up like we got
that and then we found out that they
spent all of quarantine together and
then boom award season like they're on
every red carpet like to me that would
make it seem so much more authentic this
is just like making me hate both of them
yet I guess people are getting impatient
because they don't know when award
season is gonna be that's true I mean
it's really putting
like a halt in like a lot of the major
celebrities like press schedules yeah so
I think celebrities are kind of just
like doing what they want in this time
it must be like a nice time for them to
sort of fly under the radar yeah well it
depends what kind of celebrity you are
like some celebrities literally cannot
live without like the celebrity life
like the press the fans the adoration
like they literally knew that in their
veins and then some people I genuinely
crave are lit they're like down-to-earth
they crave just like real like life yeah
and they are really loved the art of
acting and that's why they happen to
also be celebrities but really they're
just they're passionate about their
craft right that's why they got into
this line of work you know for the art
yes and they just happen to like who do
you think of as someone like that I feel
like um when I think of that I think of
like Charlize Theron oh really I think I
always think about like Jennifer
Lawrence you know the fact that she's
not even on social media she's just not
interested in the whole game like I
think when she goes to award shows she's
into it and it's fun and like it's just
exciting but generally speaking I think
she just likes the craft did I tell you
on this show that I watched bombshell I
don't think on this show I think I
really liked the show I haven't seen it
yet but I really want to and you know
what I liked about it most is that me
and Ben watched it together and
afterwards we had like a very we like to
talk about nothing like we literally
getting bad and like we we talked like
in baby talk to feel like we don't have
real conversations anymore and after
that movie that could just spawn to
really like mature in-depth conversation
just about like the me to movement and
like that's what I enjoyed like we got
to talk like adults instead I mean like
I'm a kid she ain't you boy yes you are
yes you love me and I love you yes my
boy I love you boy yes
so we sense it's so tempting just to do
that all the time that's literally what
I do when I'm around do to do to
theodora
do to do to the adora to the Dora
Dora beautiful precious Dora one and
only Dora
lovey boy Dora special angel Dora
favorite nephew Tora this song like cuz
we come via Dorothea Dora Dora the
Explorer like I'm this song just we go
on forever like we go for back and forth
soft and lovely Dora favorite man Dora
cheeks and lips Dora I love you Dora so
delicious Dora and just Dora
swirly-twirly Dora
she's angel Dora
buta motion Dora yeah no I guess we've
never shared that song but we sing it
every single time and we just go on
every day mister you know for some
reason we always start singing it when
you're putting his leash on to go out
yeah it's awful
until we have to walk separately ya know
you didn't tell everyone that you watch
a bombshell but you know what else I
didn't tell everyone that I watched a
few weeks ago for adverse is Ferrari oh
you told me about it yeah I understand
why like at the end when they give you
the true facts of the people that they
the stories about like I understand why
it felt like a story that needed to be
told but ultimately I don't think they
did a great job well I watched um
speaking of stories I didn't need to be
told been made me watch his favorite
movie and like Ben has the worst taste
in movies like if it's Ben's favorite
movie just like know that it's a piece
of [ __ ] so he made me watch um kicking
and screaming the Will Ferrell movie
where like a soccer coach yeah it was
actually pretty funny I'm sure it was I
remember it as being quite funny I feel
like it was a random selection for your
favorite movie um beyond random but very
then oh yeah it was nothing it's not
consistent
no no okay you ready for our next story
hmm I'm sad switching gears vanessab
and seeks extensive damages over the
helicopter crash that killed Kobe and
Gianna the basketball legend and his 13
year old daughter died in January
alongside the six other occupants of the
helicopter and now Vanessa Bryan is
seeking extensive damages from a
California helicopter company after
their deaths on Monday
Vanessa Bryan submitted a case summary
statement to LA Superior Court that
details the extensive damages she is
pursuing from her wrongful death lawsuit
against Island Express helicopters whose
pilot was flying a helicopter carrying
Kobe gianna and six others when it
crashed on a foggy morning on January
26th while the documents obtained my
people do not specify the exact amount
Bryan is seeking it estimates the family
has lost quote hundreds of millions in
future earnings due to Kobe's untimely
death quote as a result of Kobe Bryant's
and jeebies deaths Vanessa Bryan seeks
economic damages non-economic damages
prejudgment interest punitive damages
and other relief as the court deems just
and proper the document says although
the total specific amount of personal
injury damages that plaintiff seeks is
TBD Kobe Bryant's future lost earnings
equal hundreds of millions of dollars it
continues attorneys representing
everyone did not request but just
respond to a request for comment get it
get it get it get it my only concern is
that like there's such a big lawsuit
here like of course they're gonna win I
don't know if this like helicopter
company like sometimes you can get sued
and when you don't have the money like
you just filed for bankruptcy like
Vanessa Willie Vanessa Bryant could
hypothetically not get the money like
that's what I'm worried about I want her
and the other families like to get the
cash yeah I I want that for them as well
I haven't heard anything about um you
know the company filing for bankruptcy
yet but she just filed these papers on
Monday so I'm sure it's gonna be um
quite a road to get to what they deserve
but do you think that like a
california-based helicopter helicopter
company like has a hundred million
dollars in the bank maybe no but like
with insurance policies you know I don't
know how all of that works but yeah who
knows well
I hope they get every penny the Bryant's
and all the families that were involved
this is just like the story that keeps
like being updated and it's just like
such a pit yeah like last week would
have been Gigi's graduation it's just so
sad the pit like never gets smaller
no and Ben is like still like morning
yeah it's crazy what like I can't like
Kim believed so much has already
happened this year like what a [ __ ]
yeah this I know that poem went viral
like what if I know when he's not
canceled but like honestly this year
[ __ ] sucks like I would very much
like to cancel it but I like how people
are being optimistic and I see you and I
appreciate you and keep you in it but
I'm cancelling this year yeah no I mean
honestly everyone was like getting so
down on 20 20 then I'm glad that po-man
around because we did we do need like
some optimism and just like to be
thinking positively because if the earth
truly cancelled then that means that the
next six months like don't matter period
and we need like some positivity you
know so I like positivity
I like the poem positivity positivity
was that our fourth story no our fourth
story is some sweet mindless news
because Christian McCaffrey's Quarantine
birthday had Olivia culpo and the
unicorn cake Olivia cocoa and boyfriend
Christian McCaffrey are still in
quarantine together with his family and
her sister which is just a remarkable
feat may I say true and on Sunday they
celebrated his 24th birthday
oh he's young um and they showered the
Panthers running back with plenty of
love and a colorful unicorn cake she
posted on Instagram happy birthday to my
best friend in the whole world
unicorns really do exist I love you baby
she posted a really cute picture of them
with um a really cute cake I didn't know
Christian McCaffrey was into unicorns
but I'm here for it
I mean I saw this picture and I thought
that they got engaged I could just
they've been they haven't even been
dating for so long but in the quarantine
like to be quarantined with someone
else's family like to me there
now at the stage like of intimacy like
they've been married for five years you
know a hundred percent even people who
are married for five years I don't know
if they could have done quarantine I
think they're truly in three months with
his whole family and her sister which is
like no not it's one thing to be there
with someone's family and like be on
your best behavior and just like I feel
it she's very you know she I could see
her being a good guest in in your home
you know cuz she like it's better like
she cooks and she's fun and she's nice
whatever but like to have your sister to
and like to have to like you know just
bring her into the fold like that's a
lot of pressure yeah I feel like people
who have been married for five years
haven't actually even spent a cumulative
three months like everyday like just
timewise like I mean I see my in-laws
all the time like I don't know if like
if you added it all up with it add up to
more than three months actually too many
one because maybe with all the trips
yeah I think yeah I just I just about
hit it but still it's so different when
you have breaks in between like it's not
even the same she is on another level I
know and like do you think they want her
out or like they're like living for it I
can't tell like I'm living for it and so
from the outside um I think that
efficient mom it's like living for it
but like maybe the dad it's like I wish
all these people would get the [ __ ] out
of my house yeah that was a group that I
read that was like completely unfounded
um but you know like yeah I think I
think it's nice to have just a bunch of
different people I just can't believe
they're still there cuz I know shocking
I feel like they could have gone home if
they wanted to by now yeah I mean people
are flying commercially and you could
definitely fly private
and I also can't believe that he's
turning 24 like that hey so young that
was really surprising I did not know
that he was such a better yeah he's like
a baby but I was like a beef patty like
he's just so meaty like so like Oh Lady
so media oh wait what was um that thing
from the soup yes ooh meaty yeah that
show was so good back in the day ya know
and it's back now and it was pretty good
too and
it was what happened - it was like four
episodes I think like they had to stop
filming because of quarantine and so but
it was good but I feel like if any show
could be shot remotely its soup she
there's literally one person in front of
a green screen that's true
I don't know unfortunately I don't have
the answers so those are our four
mindful stories and then for our fifth
story we've got ourselves a little
Kelly's mindless news like okay ready
it's I mean I don't know how I live my
life without knowing this and thankfully
as always People magazine ism is at the
forefront of delivery mindless news to
the American people Kelly Ripa says Josh
Duhamel would play with her son for
hours on the set of all my children
shocking chilling for hours hours not
minutes hours Kelly Ripa is sharing a
sweet memory of Josh Duhamel during
Monday's episode of live with Kelly and
Ryan Ripa 49 opened up what she looks
really good for 49 opened up about the
first time her son Michael now 23 met
Duhamel on the set of all my children
I'm gonna tell you a story about Josh
Duhamel Ripa began before she and Ryan
Seacrest welcomed the actor as a guest
on their show this morning when we were
setting up and he was doing a sound
check I had to grab Michael and I said I
want you to see somebody when we both
worked at all my children together Josh
there's a handful of people who were
born to be parents that I've known in my
life
Josh being one of them he was like a
young kid he was in his early 20s when
we had Michael he would sit and play
with Michael who was a toddler for hours
and Michael used to call him the Iron
Giant
I can't you want me to release no please
no oh please read more please I mean I
just I'm so glad this segment exists
because it's like been this thing in my
brain where I'm like why are there
always a dumb news stories right here
and now that we're like pointing it out
I'm hoping the American people will see
the light and okay I just
share something cuz I'd seen it like a
few weeks ago when we started ki man
like the fourth of July and someone had
said like it's like we don't get these
stories out like Hoda or Jenna Bush
Hager because they like do news stories
they don't have that segment at the
beginning of their show where they like
share mindless things that they did this
week or whatever which is fine but I my
problem is like why is it written up
every single day what should like
whatever she shared in the beginning of
the show that was like truly [ __ ]
mindless you know I understand why
there's so much mindless news because
she is a daily host like she's putting
daily content he's my niceness out there
yeah and I get that but like there are a
lot of people with daily shows like that
are not news based so Kelly Clarkson
like there's a million I just want to
say like Kelly Ripa is on another level
and I just I think it's worth noting
that's it it it's definitely worth
noting and like even Ryan Seacrest like
I don't see Ryan sign this news every
day whatever he shares about like what
happened him that morning you know what
when we were looking for stories
yesterday I actually did see a piece of
mindless news he's thinking of moving to
LA full time like oh yeah demmick I saw
that too and I only found it to be
interesting and I wasn't I was almost
like but not really gonna choose a story
because remember like he's like flies
back and forth like he does his show in
LA we good hosts a live morning show in
New York like he is literally lives like
on an airplane and I think that's just
crazy like his schedule is so crazy so
when I saw he was gonna move to LA
permanently I was like good that
schedule like that life was
unsustainable it is unsustainable
and even when he made that decision he
was like ah he hosts like kiss-fm like
the number-one radio show in California
and then you're gonna host a morning
show in New York like it's just too far
no like you you actually can't be both
people you can't be a live morning host
on a show in New York and then also the
most popular radio in California even
though I think most of the time he does
his California radio from the i heart
radio station in New York which is just
like honestly like such a betrayal no
it's just not the same so I know so I
feel like I'm always seeing videos of
him like in the studio with Tanya rad
like in LA that's true actually I just
don't understand how it works for real
it's just it's it succeeds exhausting
I'm exhausted
forehand yeah whoo
tired um let's dive into TV recap and I
forgot that I do have one thing I want
to recap before we dive into the
Instagram live we're gonna talk about
okay um
RuPaul's all-stars uh new season started
on Friday and I watched it last night
first of all okay cool a toasty outfit I
can't believe they don't call it RuPaul
stars interesting
it just sounds weird to say RuPaul
all-stars so I just call it all-stars
but it should be RuPaul stars love that
I agree um I think that everyone knows
like I'ma shake who lay Stan and I just
want to put out into the universe like I
do believe she's gonna win she's uh
I mean honestly in the first challenge
she was like a little disappointing but
she's just getting her feet wet like
she's gonna figure it out she's just
like was meant to win in season nine and
like the fact that she didn't is just a
disgrace so I think she's gonna have her
moment um Blair Sinclair was like
someone I really honestly like in the
beginning she was you as a drag queen
okay
really she had a very um like soft face
like cherubic like you like she looked
like a child
um she usually had red hair and she was
very like pale skin very porcelain but
now and she was like always dressing
like she was in the fifties like
blessing class like that was her hurt
like drag aesthetic but now it's like
she went through like puberty and now
she's like a Kardashian like she wears
like short dresses and like she's just
like she went through a real um like
Genesis but I don't know I liked that
even though what she annoyed me before
like she had something specific now
she's just like everyone else yeah I
feel that
no she just like annoys me um whatever
um Ricky Martin was the guest judge and
like it was just everything of the sort
like he obviously watches drag race like
I love when you could tell someone
watches drag race like sometimes they
come on like said the press are just
like to be you know a part of the vibe
but like when you when you know someone
watch is it like it's just so much
better and Ricky Martin was an amazing
guest judge I got all the the Queen's
we're like yeah gigging the house when
he came in like it was because he's like
so [ __ ] cute um and then spoiler
alert if you don't watch yet Derrick
Barry got sent home and this is like an
interesting
element of drag race like a lot of the
Queen's are impersonators um because
that's what like a big part of being a
drag queen is like people want to go see
in Vegas like a Britney drag
impersonator so Derrick Berry has been
on um like a few seasons ago and now
he's on All Stars and like all serves is
the creme de la creme of the real
seasons and like he's just not creamy
like I don't know why he was I don't
know why he was chosen like he's stunk
and he's a Britney impersonator me
he's a Britney impersonator which is
like it's tough because the judges want
you to see want to see you do like
different looks they don't want to see
you being Britney every single time like
then that's like yeah on one trait and
he was just like oh he's [ __ ] doing
Britney literally showed him Britney
like all he did was Britney like it was
so annoying and it's like he didn't
listen to any of the critiques when he
was on his season because they didn't
want Britney and he came in and the
challenge and gave them Britney and that
was just not creamy no not creamy except
very interestingly enough like one
season and impersonator actually won um
she was a cher impersonator but she was
so much more dynamic it was just like a
part of her repertoire where's like
Derrick Berry is defined by his Britney
aesthetic and that's just not the type
of Queen you can be if you want to win
all stars understood by the way speaking
of Britney um I was watching tik-tok
last night and I just saw like such an
incredibly interesting talk I'm not sure
if you've seen it and if this is old
news but there's this tick-tock like of
this girl discovering like you know how
Britney Spears I said song my loneliness
is killing me great and later in her
career she releases a song called
stronger and it's my loneliness saying
killing me no more so it's just a little
interesting character development that I
discovered on the top shout-out to the
girl who realized that very interests
aunt okay and our final thing we want to
recap is the Instagram live that um
Bravo put on yesterday hosted by Justin
Sylvester with kandi Burruss Giselle
Bryant and Porsha Williams it was to
amplify black voices talk about
going on a lot of the house signs that I
just mentioned have been like super
involved they've been going to protests
and I just thought it was so fabulous
like for a million reasons I feel like
they reached a whole new audience of
people who like might not have tuned
into something like that if it were on
TV
um Portia went first and I'm not gonna
lie I watched Porsche and Giselle I my
sushi came and then I had two really
long like it was like I think was like
90 minutes yeah my am but my food came
in the middle also and I like took my
phone in my pocket with me like it was
like amp with like like so loud it was
um I thought it was so well done and I
just like Porsha Williams well and
Porsha and Giselle both Giselle's father
and Porsha Williams is grandfather were
both like very well-known civil rights
activists and it's clear that they like
take their legacy so seriously because
they were just like speaking truth truth
bombs left right and center like Justin
was living for it he was just like so it
was everything that like someone like me
needed you know like a combination of
everything that I love and it was just
yeah I really wanted to commend Bravo
because I thought it was like a great
platform to do it on a ton of people
were watching um and it was just they
were being like funny and powerful and
inspiring and I just Porsha and Giselle
are my favorites from I their franchise
so I thought they did a great job at
choosing those two and I did miss kandi
so I don't know what she said I want to
speak on it because I didn't see but um
I just wanted to share it's available on
their IG TV and I really thought it was
fabulous yeah it really was fabulous um
you should definitely go watch it Eddie
realizes on IG TV um that's great
because it was a great conversation and
also funny and just and empowering and
fabulous and then tonight Porsha
Porsha's back um watch repens live I
think is doing a two-hour special I
don't know if it's pre-recorded or live
um on the black lives matter movement so
she's gonna be on again tonight on TV
which it starts at 11:00 in two hours
that's like eleven to one which is
really late for Bravo I don't know why
they're doing that but I will record it
because I will definitely be asleep
oh yeah especially since we woke up
early today but that sounds so exciting
yeah it was good I really enjoyed it I
mean um it was just I don't know if I
just like loved it because I loved the
lady said her and I just like loved
everything that he does but it was
really good
no he was really good even all of the
comments like everyone was just sigh it
was it was really impactful yeah a lot
of the comments and I saw actually
Olivia sent me um there was like this
statement signed by a lot of like
well-known podcasters Bravo fan accounts
like Bravo related creators I'm asking
them to put the conversation that they
were having on Instagram live like
asking them to air it and that like they
weren't doing enough um putting it on
social media like they really wanted it
to me on TV and all the comments were
we're flooded with like you should have
put this on TV you should have put this
on TV and while I agree like a bigger
platform might have been um better I
just felt like the the format was so
well done I don't know if you could have
emulated that on TV and I know you reach
such a different group of people on
social media and there were tons of
people watching um I don't have a
problem with it being on Instagram but a
lot of people found it to be very
controversial that like baby Bravo
wasn't doing enough but they are having
this two-hour special tonight um but I
just thought that was interesting and
worth sharing that like this petition
had kind of gone around oh I haven't
seen it yet share with me oh well okay
cool well I think that is maybe all that
she wrote she looks like she's getting a
little tired me know she who's writing
oh yeah her wrist is like really
cramping so I think you should just wrap
it up they got so much for listening to
today's episode of the morning toast
Imani morning sure will we go live
Monday through Friday 10:30 a.m. Eastern
Time on YouTube so if you're watching us
on YouTube please feel free to subscribe
and give this video a thumbs up
we're also available as a podcast
anywhere podcast can be found so that's
Spotify iTunes stitcher Public Radio I
heard we do cashbox all the places
wherever you listen to podcasts find us
the morning Tosun leave a five star
review about how beautiful stunning and
smart we are we love you guys very much
thank you so much for listening to
today's episode we'll be up a fabulous
day and we'll see you tomorrow bye